يقع هذا المنزل في طريق مسدود هادئ في
الينابيع في كولورادو في موقع جيد
ويتمتع بالمناظر ويمكن تسميته ترحيبًا علويًا في محكمة تشرشل 45-25
لكن ميمي رعاية
الوكيل العقاري يطلق عليه
شيئًا آخر.  لقد كنت
أستخدم المنزل من الجحيم ، كنت
أسميه منزل ميمي الصغير من
الرعب ، المنزل خربه
مستأجر سابق تم إخلاؤه منذ أكثر من عام
وما كتبته هنا هو أنك
لن تكون قادرًا
على ذلك  استأجر هذا مرة أخرى ،
لا يوجد سطح في هذا المنزل
لا يحتاج إلى إصلاح ، لدينا تعبير
إذا كانت رائحته لن تبيع ، ومن الواضح
أنني أضع ذلك على المحك
وأيًا كان ما تفعله ، فلا
أحد لديه أي فكرة عما
يوجد بالفعل هناك
لا تفتح الثلاجة في الطابق السفلي ،
هل فهمت أنني لست متأكدًا من أنني
شممت أي شيء من هذا القبيل من قبل ،
لكن هذا المنزل أود أن أقول إن لدينا ما
لا يقل عن 250 مكالمة هاتفية اليوم ،
نعم هذا المنزل تم وضعه على
يتم بيع سوق الثلاثاء لما يقرب من
ستمائة ألف دولار نقدًا
منازل شاغرة طوال الوقت لم
أر هذا النوع من الهستيريا
حتى في هذا السوق في كولورادو. المشترين
حريصون جدًا على الدخول إلى سوق الإسكان
وهم على استعداد لدفع مبالغ
نقدية لمنازل مثل هذا المنزل
حيث سيستغرق الأمر
150000  لجعل هذا المنزل صالحًا للعيش ،
انخفض سوق الينابيع في كولورادو الذي
يحتوي عادةً على 2500 منزل معروض للبيع في أي
يوم إلى أقل من 400 منزل. لقد أدرجته
بعد ظهر أمس
وبدأ هاتفي في الرنين
بعد ظهر أمس بسبب العروض
التي تقول إن المالك اضطر إلى البيع من
قبل  فتح حبس الرهن في
نهاية الشهر ، كان
هذا المرآب المهيب رسميًا المكون من خمس غرف نوم وأربعة
حمامات ، والمرآب المكون من ثلاث سيارات
، مصدر فخر البائع وفرحه الآن
، أصبح كل كابوس مالك عقار في
قائمتهم لا يحمل أي شيء أريدهم
أن يعرفوا أنهم أصيبوا
بأضرار  منزل به الكثير من
الإمكانات
حتى مع كل عيوبه ،
فقد تمت مشاهدة المنزل أكثر من 130
ألف مرة على zillow منذ
نشره يوم الثلاثاء
وكان وكيل الإدراج هكتار  لقد
تلقيت بالفعل 16 عرضًا مكتوبًا ،
يفهم الناس المنازل أكثر
عندما تخبرهم قصة ، تأمل ميمي أن يكون
لهذه القصة نهاية سعيدة
لمن يعيش هنا بعد ذلك
،
وسيأتي شخص ما وسيتخلصون من الغضب
والكرب اللذين حدثا هنا  سيكون
مكانًا عزيزًا للعيش فيه